سنطوف على بعض الشوارع في الخرطوم لنشاهد
ماذا هناك في طبيعه هذه الشوارع في
الساعات الاولى من هذه الهدنه
هذا هو مركز عفراء للتسوق الذي كان يضج
بالحياه في كثير من الاسر وكثير من الزوار
وعمليه التسوق التي كانت مستمره طبعا في
وضعها الطبيعي ولكن الان الوضع بدا مغايرا
وليس هناك سوى الرماد والحريق هذا هو شارع
المطار والنفق الرئيسي لشارع المطار او ما
يعرف بنفق عفراء ممتلئ طبعا عن اخره
بالمياه
ونلاحظ ان هناك يعني عدد من السيارات تبدو
متعطله ربما منذ اليوم الاول من بدايه
الاشتباكات الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
اذا وصلنا الى وجهتنا الاخيره هذه الجوله
القصيره وهذه احدى المستشفيات المتخصصه في
استقبال حالات الولاده في وسط العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
في هذا المستشفى ولد الطفل في ساعات
الهدنه بعمليه قيصريه
السلام عليكم
هذا هو الطفل الذي ولد
بعمليه قيصريه هذا المستشفى موقعه كان
متاخرا لعمليات الاشتباكات المسلحه ما بين
الطرفين ما بين الجيش السوداني وبين
القوات الدعم السريع ولكن رغم ذلك ظل يقدم
خدماته بشكل طبيعي يعني طبعا نحن نتحدث عن
وضع انساني بالغ التعقيد ونتحدث عن ان 60
مستشفى متاخما لعمليات
الاشتباكات المسلحه خرجت على الخدمه بشكل
كامل ولم يتبقى سوى
ثلاثين مستشفى فقط ضل يقدم خدماته رغم
الظروف الانسانيه الصعبه والمعقده ومن
ضمنها هذا المستشفى اسامه سيد احمد
الجزيره من الخرطوم